on est au lycée wallon et on est dans
des salles qui sont dans des conditions
pitoyables on n'a pas moi ça fait trois
ans que je suis au lycée
depuis et même des personnes avant moi
ils ont dit que c'était pareil ça fait
des années que ça a pas évolué du tout
et là bizarrement depuis des médias il y
a eu quelques changements vite fait dans
les robinets ou dans les plafonds et du
coup bah on est dans des salles avec
aucun chauffage par exemple ce matin
j'ai dû passer un DST de 3 heures je on
a dû garder nos gants pour pouvoir
écrire moi j'ai écrit avec mon manteau
sur mon dos parce que j'arrivais pas
j'avais trop froid on arrive dans la
salle il fait de la même température à
l'intérieur de la salle que à
l'extérieur il fait super froid et c'est
horrible
ça fait trois ans que ça dure on va nous
dire qu'il y a des travaux mais on a
fait la grève l'année dernière aussi et
vous dites quoi
à faire que le lycée aille mieux mais ça
va pas du tout mieux
ça ne s'est jamais arrangé c'est du
camouflage qui font dans ce lycée et nos
enfants oui vont en cours et travaillent
en cours avec un manteau c'est
incroyable en première aussi et un autre
embts c'est un lycée professionnel
technologique et il y a les BTS aussi et
un internat il vous racontez entre à la
maison vous raconte et vous dit quoi
aujourd'hui il a eu deux heures de sport
dans un gymnase du lycée qui n'est pas
chauffé il a fait sport en doudoune
les cours de sport ont été banalisés
parce que les profs n'ont pas voulu
faire cours dans ces gymnases il faisait
8 degrés et ils ont banalisé du coup les
courses ce matin je pense pour le reste
de la semaine tant que ils n'allume pas
les chauffages dans la salle de prof
autorise le manteau mais d'autres profs
non plus et ça crée des conflits il y a
des rapports qui sont en rapport parce
qu'il a pas voulu enlever son manteau
alors qu'il fait et quand il vous dit
qu'il est obligé de s'éclairer avec son
téléphone c'est quoi cette histoire
c'est pas nouveau non plus ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui ça fait trois ans ça qui a
pas d'électricité
les couloirs il y a les lumières
s'étaient comme j'en étais un film
d'horreur là par exemple on a dû écrire
on a dû écrire avec les flashs parce que
l'électricité ne marche pas il y a
beaucoup de moments aussi où les
projecteurs vont s'éteindre les
ordinateurs ne marchent pas les fenêtres
ils sont cassées il y a des trous dans
le mur il y a peu d'isolation c'est des
conditions dans lequel moi je ne peux
pas travailler j'avais du mal à
consacrer je comprends Amel quand votre
fils vous l'a dit au début vous l'avez
cru ou pas vous l'a dit je fais les
conseils de classe donc j'ai vu
l'intérieur du lycée c'est réel c'est
pas des montages c'est vraiment vrai ce
qui se passe dans ce lycée c'est
horrible et je me demande comment les
enfants arrivent à travailler moi mon
fils il a eu son bac l'année dernière là
il est en BTS cette année mon plus grand
je me demande comment il a fait pour
avoir son bac et franchement je leur
tire mon chapeau c'est gamin qu'il
abandonnent pas l'école parce que c'est
super difficile de travailler dans des
conditions pareilles et je me pose la
question si dans le les beaux quartiers
de Paris c'est c'est comme ça et les
professeurs ils disent quoi et
professeur ils sont comme nous ils
disent quoi ils n'en peuvent plus
parler aujourd'hui avec des journalistes
il se cachaient la direction etc c'est
grâce au prof du coup que là en puissant
parler ici parce que des profs qui vont
envoyer des messages qui essaient de
changer quand même les conditions dans
lequel on est et qui essaye de contacter
l'éducation nationale aussi parce que
non on a essayé de contacter le rectorat
l'année dernière le directeur de l'école
vous avez été voir c'est un nouveau
directeur ils ont cru déjà il est arrivé
il avait le lycée dans cet état voilà
donc il a dit quoi
quand ils parlent avec lui là il va les
recevoir ce soir d'accord voilà mais
après tout ta page médiatique oui va
recevoir les parents d'élèves